how's it going bros my name is pewdiepie
and today we're looking at
top 10 ways humanity will become extinct
let's go i don't mean to be grim or
bleak in this video i'm just genuinely
interested
and i want to find out i remember when i
was a kid i
was watching this really popular science
program and
i remember that they talked about number
one the sun exploding
this is a good one because we know it
will for sure happen
and i remember in the science program
they said uh and that will kill every
life on the planet because we're
depending on the sun
and i was just freaking out as a little
kid i was like what
but then he said don't worry that won't
happen in a long time and i was like
all right we're good we're gonna invent
space travel before then
ill and musk will sort us out it's all
good we'll be fine
so when is the sun going to explode well
how much time do we really have
well in about 5.5 billion years and i
always find when you hear those kind of
enormous numbers it's hard to visualize
so if you look up
a cosmic calendar i found this really
simple one
1.1 million years ago humans were like
bruh
228 million years ago the dinosaurs
what's the dinosaurs like i'm pretty
sure we're gonna figure out a way to
all die before the sun
stops living all right seems pretty
naive almost to assume
but hey let's say it does happen let's
say we do
you when we somehow manage to keep
living for five billion years
and we get to witness the sun exploding
i always imagine this
being super cool right because you get
to see a supernova
up close a sun exploding in the skunk
but apparently that's not the case at
all the sun will first expand becoming a
red giant
will just die of heat lame then it will
shrink to become a white dwarf
cooling for the next billion years here
here they go of course we'll
all be long gone yeah no [ __ ] but still
can you imagine what it would be like no
we won't get to see it
there you go with a name like supernova
you think that a solar explosion would
be the most magnificent
firework we've ever seen but in reality
you likely wouldn't see anything
cool this one gets zero okay i don't
like it
next waits for humanity to die
okay this is a good one ai you've
probably heard already about the threat
of ai
robots becoming super intelligent
smarter than humans
they will eventually improve on
themselves have greater intelligence
than we'll ever know
and we'll just have to hope that
whatever goal they have
will align with ours because otherwise
we're screwed
okay i know this is a controversial
subject for people because uh
some peop there's just no shared
idea of what the threat is when it will
be a threat some say a hundred years
uh some say it's far in the future
some say it will never even happen but
with the exponential growth of
technology
it's safe to say it's an inevitability
at this point
unless for some reason we just decide uh
no
we'll we'll just stay here i'm happy
with the iphone 11.
i don't need an iphone 12. you know this
vast expansion of technology
doesn't seem like a good idea let's just
stick with iphone 11
and then that's it no more iphones
you know i don't need to know what
better graphics is going to look like if
it means that we're all gonna die one
day all right
maybe i don't need my robot fridge
walking to me
okay that's the sacrifice i'm willing to
take for the sake of humanity
uh i know some people seem skeptical to
the idea that you know okay we invent ai
what's that come on how is that actually
going to be a threat but
if you imagine uh i read in a mike stick
max
life 3.0 imagine if
there's an ant colony where we want to
build a factory
we're obviously going to get rid of all
the ants because we have a goal
that's more important and the point of
having ai would then be to make sure
that whatever goal the ai has will not
wipe us out
during the process what that is going to
be or what it's going to look like it's
hard to predict
but the threat is there and we can
understand that at least
i just find it interesting how about you
i don't know
i think the coolest thing about it is at
least if we
were able to create super intelligent ai
they will sort of become our cosmic
children
okay if humanity gets extinct there's no
limit really
in the same sense as us carbon beings
what they can accomplish
out in the universe they'll sort of
become our footprint of the universe
i think i even read somewhere that's my
source i think i read somewhere
that uh we're more likely to bump into
alien ai than actual
carbon or uh whatever sort of life form
organic life form or what you will if we
bump into aliens that's a more probable
uh scenario based on the same reason
that any sort of it's a bit this is a
bit of a dark video but anyway
it's kind of cool too ai wiping is out
i'm gonna rate it as six only because we
don't know exactly how and i can't
imagine anything cool
any sort of robot sci-fi movie i don't
know i never really liked them that much
number three a giant meteor
now unlike the sun destroying us at
least we get to see this one right
that's cool i want to see that here's a
question for you okay
that meteor is going to strike earth
right you know it's going to hit there
or there
do you go there in the middle and just
do that
or do you go to the other side of the
earth to hope that you
you're safe right uh which
which kind of personality are you which
one which one are you gonna do
again i think i read somewhere
i think it's stephen hogan that said
that uh it's
it's true right we're way overdue a
meteor statistically major asteroid hit
on earth is well overdue
right earth is long overdue for a visit
from space not by aliens but great
chunks of raw
uh-huh so we examined meteors that had
hit our earth
and how old they are and previous meteor
impact was traveling about 20 kilometers
per second
delivering energy equivalent to 20 to 40
megaton bomb
such comparatively puny events are
relatively common however
they are happy to remind us earth
crossing asteroids of this size are
predicted to reach us
every 1 600 years or so uh most of them
will hit the oceans but
a meteor might slam into a land mass
every 6 000 years on average
i mean just going back to the cosmic
calendar as well
okay here's the dinosaurs somewhere in
between they got extinct
i'm pretty sure we're gonna get a couple
more okay
but we'll invent space travel by then
okay elon musk will save us all the
billionaires are going to space
i'm sure they're just doing that for fun
and for no specific reason at
all what do you billionaires know
richard branson jeff bezos why are you
all in space
huh we're [ __ ] we're so [ __ ] god
damn billionaires
i i will rate an asteroid a little
higher though just because it's cool
i'll give it a seven seven out of ten
next up super volcano eruption
now they wouldn't be able to wipe us all
out
which is already you know many minus
points
it wouldn't be pleasant so the biggest
concern is obviously the yellowstone
super volcano
which seems like it could happen at any
point really no one really knows the
last three
three big eruptions at yellowstone's
were 2.1 million
1.3 billion and 630 000 years ago
so any day now man recent study picked
up
by news media yellowstone super volcano
could blow faster than thought destroy
all of mankind wait there's hope
this is fox news so take it as you will
we'd likely
first see intense seismic activity
across the entire park it would take
weeks or months for those earthquakes to
break up the rocks
before an eruption okay
all right oh damn america is [ __ ] if
that happens
oh god america you gotta leave dude
imagine yellowstone get erupts tomorrow
and i get canceled
because how insensitive i am that would
be the worst part of that event
sorry okay i'm gonna have to rate this
one very low i would give it a two out
of ten just because it would just take
out america
which is not good enough clearly and
honestly it would be kind of annoying to
have americans
that would have migrated everywhere and
i don't want that
not that i'm against migraine okay
moving
next up we have a bioengineered pandemic
let's go we've already seen
what a relatively not the nastiest
virus can do so i think it's safe to say
if a worse one came out we'd pretty much
be screwed
at least you know in the past okay sure
they didn't have
uh medicine and treatment and vaccines
but at least you know they didn't have
air travel
fast trains we make it so easy
for these things to spread all across
the earth so quickly
pandemics have killed more people than
wars natural panemics are unlikely to be
existential threats one of the most
famous example is
how the introduction of an extra gene in
the mouse box
the mouse version of smallpox made it
far more lethal and
able to infect vaccinated individuals
recent work on birth
has demonstrated that the contagiousness
of a disease can be deliberately boosted
by technology it gets better and cheaper
more groups will be able to make
diseases worse
great most work on bioweapons have been
done by governments looking for
something controllable because
wiping out humanity is not militarily
useful
oh great why thanks how about you
[ __ ] don't
okay i'll stick to my iphone 11 and you
guys
stop [ __ ] with viruses don't do that
don't do that because who knows
maybe one person in it working at a
chinese lab really close to another city
that's an outbreak
might just you never know what can
happen
right so basically we just know we will
be able to manufacture
uh it is theoretically possible and uh
i mean technology is the killer really
that's the main problem here
or science i guess this sort of come
hand-in-hand i've already
seen the demo of this one and i didn't
really like it i didn't care much for it
so i'm gonna have to rate this one one
i don't want it no thanks uh next one is
obviously nuclear war
which we all know about another great
thing we did as
a species you know nineteen what was in
when the first atom bomb uh was tested
were used
and that's when we knew hey we could
actually kill ourselves this is great
we managed to create something so
powerful that it can wipe us all
out awesome if you look at
the atom bomb from hiroshima in japan
and nagasaki
you know they there's an exponential
growth here
with the size of them the [ __ ] tsar
bomb i gotta see this
[Applause]
[Music]
given a parachute to slow its descent
and give the crew more time to escape
nice that's nice of them
wouldn't want to be that guy
they did escape but only just
the time rose right through the cloud
layer and kept on rising
it flattened out when the cloud was 40
miles high
the blast wave was still large enough to
be measured on its third passage around
the world
damn because the bomb was detonated two
miles above the ground
there was very little radioactive
fallout okay that's good
but the earth directly below the burst
was seared by the intense heat
rock had been turned to ash
[Music]
the bomb was four times bigger than
anything america has ever exploded
why something so large why not
it's cool equivalent of all explosive
used in world war ii multiplied by ten
imagine you're some random animal just
vibing and then yvonne throws 10
humans invented the atom bomb but no
mouse would ever build a mousetrap
albert einstein i don't know if that's a
real chord but i i quite like it
in a poll of experts at the global
catastrophic risk conference
in 2008 the future of humanity institute
estimated the probability of complete
human extinction by nuclear weapons at
one percent
within the century the probability of
one billion dead at ten percent
and probably a million okay let's try it
if it rolls six nine humanity will die
okay we're good we're good i
wanted to look up other odds the odds of
a five to ten kilometer wide asteroid
that likes of which made the dinosaur
going saying hitting the earth
is almost negligible at zero point okay
but the thing is it has happened is that
a fallacy to assume
i think it's fine we'll be fine i'll
give this one
uh a 4 out of 10. i feel like i've seen
it too much in video games i don't care
okay i think that pretty much sums it up
that wasn't 10 but
i can't count obviously so it doesn't
matter i think the main
biggest issue out of all these things is
that we're good at solving problems but
we're not
good at preventing problems and
generally as a species we lack foresight
clearly as estimated of the events of of
the past years you know we invented that
we invented fire
but it wasn't it took a long time for us
to invent the fire extinguisher putting
it that way
and that sort of applies to everything
we've ever created
and it's not that weird to assume then
that eventually will create something
that's such a big problem
that there wouldn't be enough time to
find the solution to fix it
so in reality we'll probably find some
other way to focus
[ __ ] it all up but until then subscribe
baby
like this video and i'll see you
tomorrow
unless roll six nine okay we're good see
you tomorrow